MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
IS DEMANDING AN INVESTIGATION
INTO THE ORIGINS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE DISCUSSED THIS IN AN
INTERVIEW ON FRIDAY AS THE
PRESIDENT, THIS WEEKEND,
QUESTIONED CHINA’S ROLE IN THE
PANDEMIC FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME, WONDERING IF IT WAS
ACTUALLY AN ACCIDENT.
WATCH THIS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: THE QUESTION
WAS ASKED, WOULD YOU BE ANGRY AT
CHINA?
WELL THE ANSWER MIGHT VERY WELL
BE A VERY RESOUNDING YES
BUT IT DEPENDS WAS IT A MISTAKE
THAT GOT OUT OF CONTROL OR  WAS
IT DONE DELIBERATELY?
IT’S A BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THOSE TWO, AND IN EITHER EVENT
THEY SHOULD HAVE LET US GO IN,
WE ASKED TO GO IN VERY EARLY AND
THEY DIDN’T WANT US IN, I THINK
THEY WERE EMBARRASSED.
MARIA: FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF STRATEGIST STEVE BANNON
WAS AMONG THE FIRST TO RAISE A
RED FLAG ON CHINA’S DECEPTION
AND WROTE AN OP-ED LAST MAY THAT
THE U.S. WAS ALREADY AT WAR WITH
THE COMMUNIST COUNTRY AND HE
JOINS ME RIGHT NOW TO TALK MORE
ABOUT IT STEVE IT’S GREAT TO SEE
YOU THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON
MARIA.
MARIA: STEVE THAT WAS THE FIRST
TIME THE PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
PUBLICLY RAISED THE QUESTION OF
WAS IT DELIBERATE?
I FOUND THAT STUNNING.
YOU HAVEN’T HEARD THE PRESIDENT
RAISE SUCH AN ISSUE BEFORE.
YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL ONE OF THE KEY PHRASES
THE PRESIDENT USED AND I THINK
IF I WAS IN BEIJING I’D BE VERY
NERVOUS RIGHT NOW AND HE SAID "
KNOWINGLY RESPONSIBLE", KNOWING
LY RESPONSIBLE AND I
THINK LET’S SET ASIDE FOR A
SECOND THIS IS A BIOLOGICAL CHUR
NOBLE, BUT LET’S
SET ASIDE THE LAB AND DID IT
LEAK OUT OF THE LAB WITH A
TECHNICIAN ON TRYING TO FIND A
VACCINE AND LEAVING ASIDE THE
FACT THEY HAVE A BIOLOGICAL
WEAPONS PROGRAM AND THAT’S ALL
GOING TO BE INVESTIGATED AS
POMPEO AND SENATOR COTTON
SAYS THAT’S ALL NOW BEING
INVESTIGATED BY INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES, BY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS, ET CETERA.
LET’S GO BACK TO KNOWINGLY
RESPONSIBLE.
LET’S BE PRECISE, THIS IS NOT
THE CHINESE PEOPLE AND THIS IS
NOT CHINA.
THE CHINESE PEOPLE, THE DECENT
HARD WORKING PEOPLE OF CHINA ARE
THE SINGLE BIGGEST VICTIMS HERE.
THIS IS ABOUT THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY, AND THEY ARE
KNOWINGLY RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED.
THIS IS AN ACT OF COMMISSION.
THEY KNEW AS A MATTER OF FACT NO
LATER THAN THE LAST WEEK OF
DECEMBER OF 2019, THEY KNEW THEY
HAD HUMAN-TO-HUMAN TRANSMISSION
AND COMMUNITY SPREAD.
THE FREE CHINESE AND THE
REPUBLIC OF TAIWAN NOTIFIED
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION ON
JANUARY 31.
ONE OF MY BROADCASTING PARTNERS
BROADCAST IT ON THE 31ST ABOUT
HUMAN-TO-HUMAN TRANSMISSION AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE GREAT
MARTYR OF THIS PROCESS IN CHINA,
DR.  LEE AND HIS COLLEAGUES IN
WUHAN, THE DOCTORS WERE ON WE
CHAT TELLING EVERYBODY, GET
READY WE HAVE HUMAN-TO-HUMAN
TRANSMISSION COMING INTO THE
HOSPITALS NOW.
MARIA: LET ME SHOW YOU THIS
TIMELINE.
WE HAVE A TIMELINE, BECAUSE IT
WAS DECEMBER 10, ONE OF THE
EARLIEST KNOWN CORONAVIRUS
PATIENTS FALLING ILL IN WUHAN,
CHAIN AND YOU’RE RIGHT THE
DOCTOR RAISES THE ALARM ON
THE CORONAVIRUS ON DECEMBER 30.
WHAT HAPPENS THEN, STEVE?
HE GETS ARRESTED.
HE’S DEAD NOW, AS YOU KNOW, FROM
CORONAVIRUS.
>> WELL HE’S ARRESTED AND ALSO
TORTURED.
HIS FAMILY IS PUT UNDER
SURVEILLANCE, AND THEY FORCE HIM
TO SIGN A DOCUMENT THAT SAYS
HE’S A RUMOR MONGER, THAT THESE
ARE LIES THAT THESE ARE NOT
HUMAN-TO-HUMAN TRANSMISSION.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL THAT IS
PRESIDENT XI KNOWINGLY
UNDERSTOOD THAT THEY HAD
HUMAN-TO-HUMAN TRANSMISSION.
WE ALSO KNOW NOW FROM SCOTT GOTL
EIB AND ALSO A REPORT
FROM A CHINESE DOCTORATE SOUTH
HAMPTON UNIVERSITY IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM THAT IF THEY HAD ACTED
LIKE ANY HUMAN BEING WOULD ACT,
DECENT HUMAN IF THEY ACTED AS
LATE AS THE LAST WEEK IN
DECEMBER, 95% OF ALL THIS WOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED.
THAT IS THE CRIME HERE.
THAT’S THE TRAGEDY HERE.
ALL THE 40,000 AMERICANS THAT
WILL BE DEAD BY TOMORROW MORNING
ALL THE VICTIMS IN WUHAN THAT
COULD BE TENS OR  HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS.
ALL THE DEAD IN LOMBARDI.
ALL THE DOCTOR DOCTORS AND NURSE
S, ALL OF THAT IS ON THE
CHINESE PARTY HANDS, AND
OTHER GANGSTERS AND ALSO THE
ECONOMIC CARNAGE.
IT’S GOING TO TAKE US DECADES TO
WORK OUR WAY OUT OF HERE
EVENTUALLY.
ALL OF THAT IS ON THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY NOT THE CHINESE
PEOPLE.
REMEMBER THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT CHINESE
FLYING ALL OVER THE WORLD IN THE
MONTH OF JANUARY.
THEY DIDN’T KNOW THAT THEY HAD
THE VIRUS.
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY HID
THIS.
THEY HID IT AT THE WHITE HOUSE
ON THE MEETINGS ON THE 14TH WHEN
THEY SIGNED THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION PUT OUT A DOCUMENT
ON THE 12TH AND THEN THEY TWEET
ED ON THE 14TH AFTER
CONSTANTINOPLE CONSULTATION WITH
SENIOR CHINESE MEDICAL OFFICIALS
, THERE’S NO
HUMAN-TO-HUMAN TRANSMISSION,
WHILE THEY’RE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THEN THEY GO TO DAVOS YOU’RE
ONE OF THE FIRST ONES TO REPORT
THIS , THEY DON’T TELL ANYBODY
AND ACTUALLY WHEN THEY STARTED
TO STOP THE TRANSMISSION, THE
TRAFFIC AND THE TRAVEL
INSIDE OF CHINA, THEY DIDN’T
STOP IT TO THE REST OF THE WORLD
IT TOOK DONALD J. TRUMP, THE
45TH PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, AGAINST HIS MEDICAL
ADVISOR’S OPINION BECAUSE THEY
WERE GOING OFF WHAT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION SAID.
IT WAS TRUMP THAT STOPPED THE
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL ON THE
31ST OF JANUARY.
THE BLOOD IS ON THE HANDS OF THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY AND
THE WORLD, FOR THE CHINESE
PEOPLE THE PEOPLE OF WUHAN, THE
WORLD MUST HOLD THESE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
MARIA: WILL THE WORLD HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE?
THE LYING IS CONTINUING AS WE
SPEAK, YESTERDAY THE PRESIDENT’S
TASK FORCE PRESS CONFERENCE,
THEY SHOWED A GRAPHIC OF THE
MORTALITY RATE, STEVE.
IT’S LAUGHABLE TO THINK THAT
CHINA IS ALL THE WAY AT THE
BOTTOM OF THIS CHART WHEN YOU’VE
GOT SO MANY CASES ACROSS THE
WORLD AND DEATHS.
LOOK AT WHERE CHINA IS.
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE FEWER DEATHS IN CHINA
THAN ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD?
>> I THINK IT’S VERY POWERFUL
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTUALLY
INTERRUPTED DR.  BIRX’S
PRESENTATION WHICH HE NEVER DOES
TO ACTUALLY POINT OUT, IT’S SO
EGREGIOUS.
WE HAD ON OUR SHOW YESTERDAY
FROM CHINA PEOPLE ARE SAYING THE
URNS THEMSELVES THEY
CREMATED THEM AND THERE’S 40 OR
50,000 URNS.
PEOPLE IN WUHAN THINK THERE ARE
PROBABLY OVER 100,000 PEOPLE IN
WUHAN THAT DIED AND FORGET
THE REST OF CHINA WE DON’T KNOW
BECAUSE THEY LIE ABOUT
EVERYTHING, BUT YOU ASK HOW THEY
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE, THE
RIOTOUS PEOPLE OF THE WORLD
ARE GOING TO STAND UP AND MAKE
SURE THEY ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LAID IT OUT
KNOWINGLY RESPONSIBLE.
THEY ARE KNOWINGLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE ACTS OF COMMISSION THAT
ALL OF THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED.
REMEMBER 60 DAYS AGO WE HAD THE
GREATEST ECONOMY IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THE WHOLE WORLD WAS PROSPEROUS
IF YOU LOOK FOR A GREAT 2020 A
GREAT KICKOFF TO A DECADE NOW
WE’RE LOOKING AT ECONOMIC
CARNAGE, AND THE LARGEST MASS
CASUALTY EVENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, CAUSED BYE-BYE O
LOGICAL CHURNOBLE AND THE LIES,
MISREPRESENTATIONS AND THE COVER
OF COTTON, CAUSES THE BIGGEST
COVERUP IN WORLD HISTORY.
IT’S INCUMBENT UPON THE
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES, AND
INCUMBENT UPON THE NATIONS OF
THE EARTH, TO COME TOGETHER.
MARIA: WELL THE QUESTION THAT
I’M ASKING IS ISN’T IT WILD THAT
NO ONE GOT INFECTED IN BEIJING,
WOW, WHAT A NOVEL THOUGHT.
WUHAN, A 5 BILLION PEOPLE START
TRAVELING SOME PEOPLE WENT TO
ITALY AND SOME WENT TO THE
UNITED STATES, BY THE WAY
433,000 PEOPLE TRAVELED CHINA TO
THE UNITED STATES AFTER IT WAS
KNOWN THAT THE CORONAVIRUS WAS
HAPPENING, BUT NOBODY GOT INFECT
ED IN BEIJING.
I’VE GOT TO MOVE ON TO THE
ELECTION.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO IMPACT THE
ELECTION, DO YOU THINK JOE
BIDEN IS GOING TO BE THE
DEMOCRAT CANDIDATE GIVEN HIS
EXPERIENCE WITH CHINA?
>> WELL FIRST OFF HE’S BY FAR
THE WEAKEST CANDIDATE TOTALLY
COMPROMISED.
REMEMBER PRESIDENT OBAMA
BASICALLY HAD BIDEN AS HIS WING
MAN TO DO EVERYTHING WITH CHINA.
HIS COMPROMISE BY THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY HE IS PERSONALLY
COMPROMISED BY THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY AND THAT IS ALL
LAID OUT IN DETAILS AS FAMILIES
IN BUSINESS WITH HIM BUT HE’S
MADE EVERY BAD DECISION IN THIS
MANAGED DECLINE OF THE
UNITED STATES, IT WAS JOE
BIDEN REMEMBER JOE BIDEN WAS
SAYING LAST SUMMER, HEY, CHINA’S
NOT NO PROBLEM, CHINA ISN’T A
PROBLEM IT WAS JOE BIDEN THAT
TOOK THE SIDE OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
HE WAS A USEFUL IDIOT FOR THE
CHINESE, BUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP STANDS UP AND SAYS HEY
WE’VE GOT TO STOP THE TRAFFIC
COMING IN HERE AND WE HAVE TO
QUARANTINE THE PEOPLE THAT COME
IN.
IT WAS BIDEN THAT TOOK THE
BEIJING PARTY LINE.
IT WAS BIDEN THAT WENT RIGHT TO
IT’S XENOPHOBE.
MARIA: SO IS HE THE CANDIDATE?
>> I THINK THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS NO CHANCE OF BEATING DONALD
J. TRUMP WITH JOE.
IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
JOE BIDEN IS TOTALLY COMPROMISED
BY THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
AND BY HIS ACTIONS AND BY THE
WAY, I’M NOT EVEN GOING TO
SAY ANYTHING ABOUT HIS HEALTH
AND HOW FUZZY, HOW UNFOCUSED HE
LOOKS WHEN HE COMES ON HIS PROOF
OF LIFE PODCAST THAT HE PUTS OUT
EVERY THREE WEEKS.
RONA MCDANIEL SAYS --
MARIA: SO IS HE THE CANDIDATE OR
NOT?
STEVE?
>> I THINK AT THE CONVENTION
THEY WILL LOOK VERY SERIOUSLY
REPLACING BIDEN AND HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT COULD REALLY TAKE
ON TRUMP.
BIDEN CANNOT TAKE ON DONALD J.
TRUMP NO WAY NOT ON CHINA OR
ANY OTHER TOPIC.